president steinmeier
secretary general guterres dr tedros
distinguished guests i'm honored
to be a patron of this year's world
health summit
and i'm delighted to be able to speak to
you today
even if i wish it could be in person
last year's edition with more than 2
500 participants and 300 speakers from
100 nations
feels very difficult to imagine only 12
months
on this event has long reflected the
global and interconnected nature of
health
in the 21st century and looking back
now this is something i perhaps
had not fully grasped as a student when
i saw medicine primarily through a
scientific lens
and while i started to understand it
more
as a doctor in obstetrics and gynecology
the nature of my work was still very
narrowly
focused on the clinical and
the individual it is important
but it was only later when working
at the department of epidemiology at
the hanover medical school that i really
learned what global health meant
and there's one story from the time
the story of an epidemiologist
that i think illustrates this better
than i could explain
it was back in february and march 2003
just as i was moving from medicine to
become state minister
with responsibility for health amongst
other things
at the exact same time on the other side
of the world
a sars super spreading event was taking
place
on the ninth floor of the metropole
hotel in hong kong
and within days the virus has
had spread as far as singapore canada
and vietnam
and it was in hanoi that dr
carlo urbani an infectious disease
specialist
was working for the who
here was an italian doctor
working in a french hospital in vietnam
treating an american patient who himself
had fallen sick in hong kong
he recognized at first that this
was a sars-like respiratory disease and
he was the first
to trigger the alarm and in doing so
he saved countless lives everywhere from
thailand to toronto
and probably far beyond
i mentioned this story firstly to pay
tribute to
dr urbani who as many of you will know
became infected shortly afterwards and
sadly passed away
leaving a young family behind
also to illustrate how linked our health
is
and how important global cooperation is
more than at any point in human history
the health of one country
directly affects that of another
and cross-border viruses need
cross-border responses
especially as we move into the next
phase of this pandemic
the dramatic spikes in recent weeks
across the world
and especially here in europe reflect
the picture
that is getting worse by the day so we
are back
to march and april levels and in many
cases already far beyond it
but while the virus is back stronger
than ever
our knowledge and our experience of what
we need to do
is also much better than before
and i would like to focus on three areas
where this will be critical in the next
month ahead of us
the first is the need for coordination
across
borders at the beginning
of the pandemic unilateral border
closures threatened
our ability to manage the health crisis
and our ability to keep our societies
and economies going
in response we created green lanes
to ensure the availability of goods and
essential services
but this pointed to the crucial
importance of early
and effective cross-border cooperation
the virus does not respect any borders
and this is why the commission last
month
set out how measures taken by member
states
should be coordinated and communicated
we now have common criteria and
thresholds when deciding whether to
introduce travel restrictions
we have a map with a single set of
colors
where everyone agrees which regions are
red
orange or green and we
now need a single set of rules for what
testing and quarantine people have to do
if they are traveling from a high-risk
zone
the second area where we need to draw on
our experience is the supply of
equipment
in response to shortages at the
beginning of the pandemic
europe took swift action to ensure that
industry here in europe
could ramp up the production of masks of
gloves
tests ventilators and all the other
essential equipment
we created a common european reserve for
medical equipment
and through our civil protection
mechanism that's how we call it
we can now ensure that it is distributed
to where it is needed most
like for example the 30 ventilators that
we are now sending
to czechia
also the need to diversify some of our
supply chains and critical areas
will be a key focus in the weeks and
months and years ahead of us
in the meantime we know that almost
every country
will take drastic and difficult measures
to contain the spread of the virus
rightly so people are once again being
asked
to make painful sacrifices we owe it to
them
to all pull in the same direction
to protect their lives and their
livelihoods
and this is the third area i would like
to discuss
we need to ensure that we support people
and that we support the economy
and this is why we created shure
this is a temporary instrument to keep
people
in work and in the companies in business
it will be funded by 100 billion euros
issued through social bonds and it will
now start supporting short time work
schemes
in at least 16 member states
and in parallel our recovery plan we
call it next generation eu
will finance 750 billion euros of
investment and reform
to kick-start our economy to strengthen
our health
systems and to accelerate europe's twin
green and digital transition
ladies and gentlemen
the point is we cannot wait for the end
of the pandemic
to repair and prepare for the future and
this is why
we will be putting forward proposals to
improve our ability to collectively
respond to serious cross-border health
threats we will strengthen our medicines
and scientific agencies
the ecdc and emma
and we will build a new european agency
for
biomedical advanced research and
development
and we will build the foundation of a
stronger european health union
in which 27 countries work together
to detect prepare and respond
collectively
on the one hand we have seen the limits
of what europe can do without competence
in this area
and we do need to have a real debate on
this
because on the other hand we have seen
the real added
value when countries cooperate and
coordinate on
everything from data to criteria
only this week the commission has set up
an eu-wide gateway
for national tracing apps to ensure they
safely
interoperate and interact with each
other
so tracing apps from germany ireland and
italy for example are now linked
to this gateway and czechia denmark
latvia spain and many others will soon
also follow this will help
people who work or travel across borders
and ensure we are all pulling together
all pulling together this must be the
hallmark of the european health union
and i believe this can be a test case
for
true global health compact
the need for leadership is clear and i
believe
the european union must assume this
responsibility
and this is why i will convene a global
health
summit next year alongside prime
minister conte
and the italian g20 presidency the aim
will be
to bring all global efforts together to
learn the lessons of the crisis
and to update global health cooperation
for this age of pandemics we
really need to rally around a set of
international commitments
investments and principles for the next
decade of global health cooperation
and we have been laying the groundwork
for this ever since the pandemic started
in april the european commission helped
launch the
act accelerator initiative
an initiative to globally coordinate and
speed up the development
and fair allocation of vaccines
treatments and diagnostics
then in may we brought more than 40
countries together
to raise the necessary 16 billion euros
again for universal access to tests
treatments and vaccines
and to support the economic recovery of
the world's most fragile regions and
communities
and this was a truly global effort
it was supported by many many for
example global citizen
the bill and melinda gates foundation
the welcome trust
the who the global preparedness
monitoring board just to name some
and then in august the european
commission joined the kovacs facility
it is co-hosted by gavi contributed
400 million euros for pooled
procurement and equitable distribution
of covered 19 vaccines
around the world but we all know there
is
way more work to do and we know that
developing a vaccine won't save lives in
itself
but vaccinations will
so we need to ensure that those who need
them most
urgently can get it first
the health workers the vulnerable the
older generation
the european commission has been working
hard to make
agreements with pharmaceutical companies
and secure future doses we must now get
ready
to deploy it both in europe with our
recent vaccination strategy
and of course around the world
and we will not stop once the first
vaccinations have been administered
because way more important is that we
will centrally collect
robust data and robust evidence
to assess the impact the effectiveness
and any side effects
of these vaccines national immunization
technical advisory groups
will in close cooperation with ecdc
and the ema play a key role
in the coordination of large-scale
eu-wide studies
that are monitoring the safety and the
effectiveness
of covet-19 vaccines
preparation for these activities must
start now they must start now to be in
place
when covet 19 vaccines reach the
european market
ladies and gentlemen only with trust
and with transparency about the process
will we overcome any doubts or
disinformation
but for the longer term i believe it is
time for the world
to change its mindset on health
we need to move away from looking after
our health
only through clinical individual
outcomes
in today's world we need to look after
our health
by looking after our planet our
well-being
and our sustainable development
and we need to do it together through
global health
cooperation and not through global
health competition
and this is the aim of this conference
and this is what you can count on europe
for
in the difficult period ahead and in the
decade
that follows thank you so much